ich freue mich sehr dass der
österreichische bundeskanzler sebastian
coates heute wieder einmal bei uns zu
gast ist und das ist deshalb so
besonders erfreulich weil wir die
gelegenheit hatten einmal vor dem
nächsten europäischen rat ende juni
jetzt aber vor allen dingen auch bevor
österreich seien die nächste
präsidentschaft übernimmt uns
miteinander auszutauschen über die
schwerpunkte der österreichischen
präsidentschaft und natürlich wollen wir
soweit das möglich ist auch
unterstützend tätig zeit sein um dieser
präsidentschaft zum erfolg zu verhelfen
wir sind uns einig dass europa in einer
schwierigen situation ist wenn man sich
die globale situation an betrachtet und
insofern es wichtig ist dass in den
handlungsfeldern wo gemeinschaftliches
handeln uns auch einen platz in der welt
sichert das in diesen handlungsfeldern
europa start sein muss dass europa
geeint sein muss und das ist auch das
was mich umtreibt was uns aber auch
gemeinsam umtreibt und daraus ergeben
sich auch die schwerpunkte die der
bundeskanzler natürlich sehr viel besser
darstellen kann ich habe meinen
darlegungen ja in den letzten tagen und
wochen immer wieder gesagt dass wir
bestimmte herausforderungen haben einmal
die außenpolitische herausforderung
gemeinsam zu agieren
mich hat haben die erlebnisse des g7
gipfels in kanada darin noch einmal
bestärkt zum zweiten dass das große
thema der migration der illegalen
migration ein thema ist dass wir europa
einheitlich verantworten müssen das ist
für mich sehr wichtig ich glaube dieses
thema hat das potential europa schweren
schaden zuzufügen nebenraum der
freizügigkeit im schengen raum
deshalb stimmen wir auch darin überein
dass gerade der außengrenzen schutz ein
zentraler punkt ist um auch illegale
migration zu begegnen und natürlich
fällt in die zeit der österreichischen
präsidentschaft auch die erwartung ob
man vielleicht ein mittelfristigen
finanziellen rahmen schaffen kann
das wäre natürlich sehr wünschenswert
in europa sollte auch nach der
europäischen wahl die jetzt schon in
weniger als einem jahr stattfindet sehr
schnell handlungsfähig sein und die
programme entwickeln können für das für
die zeit ab 2021
das ist eine herkulesaufgabe bei der wir
auch unterstützung zusagen würden aber
die natürlich nicht ganz einfach zu
erledigen ist
alles in allem also die bereitschaft von
deutscher seite gemeinsam mit österreich
zu arbeiten und einen beitrag dazu
leisten dass europa stärker wird das
europa geeint ist und damit auch ein
wichtiger partner in der welt und das
glaube ich wäre für die bürgerinnen und
bürger europas eine gute machen sehr
geehrte damen und herren geschätzte frau
kanzlerin vielen dank für die einladung
nach berlin vielen dank für die
möglichkeit auch das austausch ist heute
es ist schon angesprochen worden wir
übernehmen mit erster juli den
ratsvorsitz in der europäischen union
keine einfache aufgabe wenn man bedenkt
wie gerade die geopolitische situation
ist dass wir gerade dabei sind den
austritt großbritanniens abzuwickeln und
das ist die letzte präsidentschaft ist
die letzte vollständige präsidentschaft
vor den wahlen zum europäischen
parlament es stehen 300 trilogie an die
noch abgeschlossen werden sollen
zumindest überall dort wo es möglich ist
es steht eine fülle an themen an die
abgearbeitet werden soll bevor es dann
in richtung wahlen zum europäischen
parlament geht und es gibt natürlich
themen die uns beschäftigen werden die
wir uns nicht aussuchen können
das ist zum ersten der praxis und das
ist zum zweiten die verhandlungen über
den mehrjährigen finanzrahmen das eu
budget
darüber hinaus haben wir als
präsidentschaft natürlich die
möglichkeit auch einen nationalen
schwerpunkt zu setzen
wir fokussieren hier ganz bewusst auf
das thema der sicherheit mit dem motto
europa
das schützt als ziel komme gerade aus
israel
und immer wenn man dort ist dann ist man
dankbar in einer region leben zu dürfen
wo sicherheit selbstverständlichkeit ist
damit die sicherheit aber in europa
selbstverständlichkeit bleibt braucht es
unserer meinung nach eine stärkere
kooperation in sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik auf europäischer
ebene
und es braucht doch eine lösung für die
migrationsfrage um die innere sicherheit
in unserer europäischen union zu
gewährleisten
wir werden daher beim gipfel der staats
und regierungschefs am zwanzigsten
september auf dieses thema fokussieren
wir werden nach langen diskussionen über
die verteilung innerhalb der
europäischen union vor allem unseren
schwerpunkt auf den außen grenzschutz
legen wir wollen eine stärkung von
frontex personell finanziell aber auch
mit einem robusteren mandat ausgestattet
um sicherzustellen dass auch die zahl
der ankünfte an der europäischen
außengrenzen reduziert wird nicht jeder
der auf der welt unter verfolgung leidet
kann in europa oder in mitteleuropa ein
besseres leben finden wir müssen daher
die außengrenzen schützen und
gleichzeitig die hilfe vor ort ausbauen
um den menschen in den herkunftsländern
bestmöglich zu helfen das wird der fokus
für den gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs sein ich darf mich da
auch bedanken wenn wir unterstützung aus
deutschland erhalten um hier einen
ordentlichen schritt voranzukommen
ganz allgemein gesprochen ist unser ziel
natürlich eine europäische union zu
unterstützen die noch stärker werden
soll in zukunft vor allem durch
fokussierung wir bekennen uns zu einem
europa der subsidiarität und werden
daher auch im rahmen des ratsvorsitzes
eine schwerpunktsetzung auf das thema
subsidiarität legen mit dem ziel eine
europäische union dahingehend zu
unterstützen wo es einen stärkeren fokus
auf die großen fragen gibt und
gleichzeitig ein sich zurücknehmen in
den fragen wo nationalstaaten oder
regionen auch selbst entscheiden können
ich freue mich dass wir gemeinsam jetzt
noch mit unserem neuen wirtschaftskammer
präsidenten harald mahrer der mich nach
berlin begleitet hat
zum wirtschaftstag der cdu weiter ziehen
dürfen vielen dank
herr bundeskanzler sie sind mitten in
eine sehr aktuelle debatte in
deutschland jetzt hereingekommen es geht
um das thema zurückweisungen von
flüchtlingen an grenzen davon wäre wenn
es dazu käme in erster linie österreich
sehr stark betroffen daher meine frage
haben sie die deutsche kanzlerin in
ihrer haltung bestärkt dass es eben
nicht zu einer lösung kommen soll oder
sehen sie sich da mehr auf seiten der
bayerischen csu die sie ja sonst auch
immer unterstützt haben in vielen ihrer
forderungen und frau bundeskanzlerin
[Musik]
müssen wenn sie hier gut zweite frage
stellt bekommt kein anderer kollege aus
österreich mehr eine chance dann ja also
ich möchte mich in diese innerdeutsche
debatte nicht ein was geist dass wir als
österreich ein ziel haben nämlich den
zustrom illegaler migration an
flüchtlings und migrationsströme nach
europa zu stoppen wir sind hier immer
konsequent gewesen in unserer haltung
und werden daher auch den ratsvorsitz
nehmen nutzen um hier an einer
ordentlichen europäischen lösung zu
arbeiten die starke europäische lösung
kann nur ein funktionierender außen
grenzschutz sein
wir müssen entscheiden wir nach europa
kommen darf und nicht die schlepper und
daher werden wir auch in dem sinne wie
ich sie einen gerade skizziert habe
unseren ratsvorsitz nutzen
und da hoffentlich einen ordentlichen
schritt voranzukommen
herr bundeskanzler ich wollte zu den
finanzen fragen und zu den vorschlägen
die herr marco auf den tisch gelegt hat
die bundeskanzlerin hat sich jetzt dafür
ausgesprochen einen zweistelligen
milliardenbetrag für euro länder zur
verfügung zu stellen in denen müsste
österreich ja dann auch mit einzahlen
werden sie damit einverstanden und
anschlussfrage an das was eben gerade
gefragt wurde was wären die konsequenzen
einer zurückweisung von flüchtlingen auf
österreich würden sie dann wie in einem
dominoeffekt auch die österreichischen
grenzen für diejenigen schließen die
schon in anderen eu ländern registriert
sind
also vielleicht zu ihrer ersten frage
wir haben hier eine sehr klare position
eine position die auch sehr nahe an den
niederlanden an der position der cdu und
csu ist
ich kenne diesen kompromissvorschlag der
jetzt am tisch liegt wir werden dann
prüfen sind dem aber nicht abgeneigt
die ideen von macau in diesem bereich
euro finanzminister eine totale
vergemeinschaftung der schulden das ist
etwas das wir so definitiv nicht
unterstützen
zu ihrer zweiten frage vieles von dem
was in deutschland diskutiert wird tun
wir schon wir haben in den letzten
monaten auch maßnahmen gesetzt das neue
bundesregierung um den zustrom illegaler
migranten nach österreich zu reduzieren
wir haben die außer landes bringen
verstärkt und wir haben auch erste
reformen eingeleitet
in unserem sozialsystem zum beispiel was
die österreichische mindestsicherung
betrifft um hier auch als land nicht
mehr so eine anziehungskraft zu haben
für menschen die quer durch europa
ziehen und dann ihren asylantrag in
österreich zu stellen ich glaube was
entscheidend ist ist dass wir es beenden
dass menschen am quer durch europa
ziehen
dann in österreich deutschland oder in
schweden ihren asylantrag zu stellen das
entspricht nicht den dublin regeln und
ist doch etwas was so nicht
funktionieren kann
ich glaube dass die österreichische
präsidentschaft auch mit der
unterstützung deutschlands und der
kanzlerin wirklich die chance hat hier
einen ordentlichen schritt voran zu
kommen was die sicherung der
außengrenzen betrifft denn nur wenn wir
einen ordentlichen außen grenzschutz
zustande bringen dann wird das europa
ohne grenzen nach innen auch in zukunft
existieren frau bundeskanzleramt was
sebastian kurz gerade skizziert hat ist
das für sie eine ausländerpolitik ja ein
vorbild oder hier ein abschreckendes
beispiel
also ich persönlich glaube dass wir uns
übereinstimmen darin dass wir den
außengrenzen schutz verstärken müssen
mir persönlich ist wichtig dass wir
nachhaltige lösungen bekommen und
deshalb möchte ich die dinge auch auf
europäischer ebene diskutieren und auch
an die europäischen regelungen mich
halten also das was die dublin regeln
beinhalten
ich glaube veränderungen sollten
gemeinsam stattfinden wir brauchen aber
dringend veränderungen und deshalb setze
ich auch auf den jetzt noch mal
stattfindenden eu rat ende juni aber
dann auch auf aktivitäten der
österreichischen präsidentschaft was wir
nicht machen sollten ist aus meiner
sicht sozusagen wenigen ländern bei
denen dann die flüchtlinge ankommen die
gesamte verantwortung zuzuschieben
sondern wir müssen gemeinsam miteinander
die lösung finden und ich habe immer
wieder gesagt das hat ja auch viele
diskussionen hervorgerufen das für mich
ein beispiel zum beispiel dieses eu
türkei abkommen war mit dem dann ja auch
wirklich die zahl der ankommenden
zurückgegangen ist manchmal haben wir
nicht darüber was hat die balkanroute
gebracht aber ich glaube wir sind uns
einig dass mit den türken abkommen noch
mal ein wichtiger schritt gegangen wurde
und mir liegt daran dass in europa
gemeinsam zu beschließen und nicht
unilateral zu agieren
frau bundeskanzlerin die csu hat sich
weitgehend festgelegt auf die schließung
der außengrenzen für bestimmte migranten
die unionsfraktion hat gerade wenn wir
das richtig verstanden haben aus den
informationen aus teilnehmerkreisen sie
mehr oder weniger aufgefordert doch an
seehofer in diesem punkt
entgegenzukommen welche möglichkeiten
sehen sie denn in dieser woche noch zu
einem kompromiss mit herrn seehofer zu
kommen der auch ihre europapolitische
verantwortung die sie gerade betont
haben wo sie der gerecht werden können
also richtig ist erst einmal dass ich
insgesamt diesen masterplan für
ausgesprochen wichtig halte ich habe
horst seehofer auch immer darin
unterstützt das einmal komprimiert
zusammen geschrieben wird was wir
insgesamt im umgang mit migration
brauchen von den außenpolitischen
maßnahmen über die europapolitischen
ausnahmen bis zu den innenpolitischen
maßnahmen an einer stelle gibt es
diskussionsbedarf wir haben uns darauf
verständigt und das auch der fraktion
gesagt dass wir miteinander weiter
sprechen wollen sie haben kennen meine
prioritäten und jetzt werden diese
gespräche geführt
herzlichen dank
wir haben
das tor
[Musik]